الصور الاوليه
لعمليه انقاذ سيده تبلغ من العمر سبعه
وسبعين
عام او عمر 42 سنه في كهرمان مرعش بعد
بقائها
222 ساعه تحت الانقاض طبعا الفرق الانقاذ
قالت بان الوضع الصحي لهذه السيده
جيد مقارنه بالوقت الطويل الذي امضته تحت
الانقاض انقاض مبنى مهدم تماما في كهرمان
مراش طبعا هذه الصور تتكرر في خلال
الساعات الماضيه يصفها المسعفون وسيله
بانها معجزات تحصل في هذه المناطق نظرا
للوقت الطويل الذي يقضيه من يخرجون احياء
من تحت انقاذ مناطق لاحظوا
الذي يلف المنطقه دمار واسع في كهرمان
مراشيه مركز طبعا الزلزال المدمره التي
ترى ضرب تركيا وشمال سوريا نذكر هذه الصور
الاوليه التي وصلتنا
لانقاذ فرق الاغاثه التركيه
لسيده تبلغ من العمر 42
عاما في كهرمان مراش بعد بقائها 200
وعشرين ساعه تحت الانقاض
جلال ومثل ما قال المتحدث باسم فريق
الانقاذ الذي انتشل المراه بان وضعها جيد
مقارنه بالمده الزمنيه التي قضتها تحت
الانقاض نتحدث عن عشره ايام كامله تحت
الامر
[موسيقى]